buongiorno a tutti allora oggi di palo
di agricoltura e non vi voglio però
parlare di cibo perché ne abbiamo
sentito parlare molto l'anno scorso
durante expo ma vi vorrei parlare di
paesaggio perché agricoltura vuol dire
anche paesaggio vuol dire ambiente vuol
dire gestire il territorio ed è un
qualche cosa che come il cibo interessa
a tutti noi perché noi siamo quello che
mangiamo ma siamo anche l'ambiente in
cui viviamo non vieta ma è così e quindi
ci deve interessare come è gestito
l'ambiente in cui viviamo
negli ultimi negli ultimi decenni noi
abbiamo assistito a una modifica
sostanziale dell'ambiente in cui viviamo
abbiamo assistito una modifica delle
periferie abbiamo assistito soprattutto
a una modifica delle campagne ed è una
cosa molto evidente io adesso ho
scaricato un po di immagini da dal web
però basta farsi un giro che so io sulla
via emilia
oppure andate via cercare la via appia
ho appena letto recentemente il libro di
rum iss per vedere dei paesaggi che sono
tutt'altro che belli sono abbastanza
depressivi e campagne che magari sono
anche profondamente degradate non solo
periferie in cui vediamo i segni di una
forte di un forte degrado
questa questo degrado e opera ovviamente
dell'uomo e opera prima della forte
industrializzazione che è stata fatta in
alcune aree del non solo del nostro
paese ma anche di una diversa gestione
della della campagna di una diversa
gestione delle periferie qui vedete
attorno a roma bene oppure ecco in come
in questo caso abbiamo una diversa
gestione della campagna con dei problemi
notevoli
questa è una fotografia presa nelle
nelle grandi pianure degli stati uniti
nel commonwealth
ma è un problema che abbiamo anche qui
in italia perché si fanno campi sempre
più grandi l'avrete
avete fatto caso no campi sempre più più
grandi si devasta in un certo senso il
paesaggio perché se questa necessità di
meccanizzare estremamente l'atto
agricolo è però i terreni non più
protetti sono soggetti all'erosione del
vento
abbiamo un fenomeno nuovo basta leggere
le cronache durante l'estate qui nella
pianura padana e abbiamo delle
fortissime trombe d'aria che una volta
non esistevano perché la velocità del
vento era bloccata dalle piante dagli
alberi dalle siepi e oggi invece
abbattendo alberi e siepi abbiamo dei
fenomeni che assomigliano un po a quelli
che delle grandi pianure americane che
cosa è avvenuto nel 1950 in italia
c'erano 20,9 milioni di ettari oggi per
l'agricoltura sono destinati 12,4
milioni di ettari
mancano all'appello 8,5 milioni di
ettari e qui andiamo un po nel dettaglio
5,2 milioni di ettari sono superfici
diciamo inselvatichite coperte da da
boschi
si tratta generalmente di superfici
nella media dalla media collina in su
fino a in montagna 1,9 milioni di ettari
sono terreni marginali inutilizzati
lungo le strade non coltivati e abbiamo
anche 1,3 milione di ettari di terreni
completamente coperti da cemento o
asfalto
tanto per darvi un'idea perché il
milione di ettari magari 8,5 milioni ha
con gli atri che mancano all'agricoltura
italiana e sono la superficie delle tre
più grandi regioni italiane piemonte
lombardia e sicilia
gli 1,3 milioni di ettari che abbiamo
visto sono stati diciamo fra virgolette
cementificati
corrispondono alla superficie
dell'intera campania
quindi mi sto parlando di un fenomeno
piuttosto macroscopico il cemento quindi
è passato ma non vi voglio parlare di
questo da 0,8 a 2,1 milioni di ettari
non a caso è cresciuta la popolazione
italiana si dal 1950 ad oggi non so 15
milioni di persone però i vani sono
passati da 35 a 120 milioni
mi sono meravigliato quando io sono un
agronomo non sono un urbanista quando
sono nata a vedere questi dati mi sono
meravigliato perché credevo che il
fenomeno forse qualche cosa degli anni
50 60 70 non so li ricordate quel film
di rosi mani sulla città jeans parlare
di speculazione edilizia e invece è la
fortissima tensione la curva della
cementificazione parte dal 1992 ea
l'acme proprio negli ultimi anni dal
2000 al 2011 quando si blocca la
cementificazione ma non per nostra
volontà o per volontà di chi ci governa
ma perché c'è stata una crisi economica
è uno degli effetti a mio parere
benefici della crisi economica e è
cresciuta la popolazione italiana di un
milione di persone
però sono stati costruiti 1,57 milioni
non divani di alloggi quindi vedete il
fenomeno come è stato forte non a caso
il consumo di cemento in italia è il più
alto in assoluto nell'unione europea 565
kg pro capite contro i poco più di 400
in europa la media europea ma no non vi
voglio far vedere solamente delle cose
brutte perché in italia ovviamente
abbiamo ancora tanti paesaggi molto
belli paesaggi molto belle che sono
paesaggi nostri paesaggi che ci
appartengono e fa parte del bene comune
del bene comune perché perché il
paesaggio è importante esiste una
psicopatologia del paesaggio
vi dico un'altra vieta chi vive in un
brutto posto sembra quel quel comico di
passaglia chi vive in un brutto posto
sta molto peggio di chi vive in una
bella campagna ben ordinata verde in
civile in una brutta periferia
ovviamente è soggetto molto di più per
esempio a a depressione ma è la mano
dell'uomo che modella il territorio dove
abbiamo una buona agricoltura qui nel
caso abbiamo della viticoltura dove c'è
una bella viticoltura conoscerete tutti
che so io il chianti montalcino le
langhe e così via
dove c'è la possibilità agli agricoltori
di campare bene e con decoro
allora il territorio è bello e ben
curato e diventa anche una risorsa una
risorsa per esempio dal punto di vista
turistico
il marketing territoriale è un aspetto
che interessa assai interessante ma io
me ne sto occupando da qualche tempo ed
è un aspetto estremamente interessante
una risorsa formidabile per per l'italia
quindi vi faccio vedere ancora qualche
del paesaggio per esempio anche dei
paesaggi che sembrano non agricoli come
in questo caso nelle valli di comacchio
in realtà sono praticamente fabbricati
totalmente dall'uomo dall'operazione
umana e non sarebbe possibile gestire il
territorio un territorio molto fragile
estremamente fragile come quello
italiano senza l'agricoltura
purtroppo oggi abbiamo notevolissimi
problemi voi anche qui leggete le
cronache e a fine estate per esempio con
gli acquazzoni o o durante o alla fine
primavera vedete che ci sono smottamenti
frane danni formidabili che costano
costano tutti noi quando vediamo qui
sulle nostre colline smottare dei
terreni perché magari sono terreni
inutilizzati
alla fine si devono ricostruire delle
strade e le paga il contribuente non vi
dico poi c'è anche un certo numero di
vittime purtroppo tutti gli anni
perché in regioni con un forte dissesto
tipo la liguria la campania
voi pensate che in liguria mi sembra su
232 comuni 230 anni sono in emergenza di
dissesto idrogeologico quindi è un
problema veramente forte nazionale e
anche con un risvolto negativo economico
oltre che che sociale talora drammatico
questo è il famoso dipinto del del buon
governo
a siena anche perché è necessario agire
in questo senso
avete visto che ci sono due fenomeni io
ho fatto vedere due fenomeni
un fenomeno della fortissima
urbanizzazione magari degrado anche che
il troviamo nella pianura
voi pensate a alla pianura padana non
solo andatevi a leggere e quello che
scrivevano i grandi viaggiatori di
quelli del grand tour che arrivavano
anche a bologna o giravano la pianura
veneta oggi ci sono larghe fasce di
questa pianura che sono completamente
coperte per esempio di capannoni sono
tutt'altro tutt'altro che belle
purtroppo ma abbiamo anche un altro
fenomeno quello dei 5,2 milioni di
ettari che vi dicevo prima di rin
selvatici mento bene a me è capitato io
sono un camminatore andare in collina
vedere sotto quello che succede nella
nella valle se proprio l'impressione di
essere in una dimensione completamente
differente sotto il caos sopra il
selvatico diciamo ed è un problema
italiano perché abbiamo una parte del
paese che è un paese parallelo in cui si
è avuto una notevole
deindustrializzazione e ma è un paese
praticamente disabitato con problemi
anche di gestione del territorio e di
conseguenza anche di dissesto
idrogeologico o anche problemi di
carattere sociale problema vi dico il
bene comune ci sarà chi parla dopo di me
che ben ha ben altra cultura velo
accenno solamente la cena solamente e
questa è una è una cooperativa di
pescatori del maine che abbiamo premiato
dell'anno scorso con il bologna award e
sono dei pescatori che agiscono con i
consumatori per hanno fatto capire ai
consumatori che il mare il pescato è un
bene comune e hanno operato hanno fatto
dei progetti molto molto interessanti di
pesca sostenibile sostenuti soprattutto
dai consumatori e adesso vi faccio in
qualche caso perché poi il tempo scorre
perché ho chiesto a degli amici e
giornalisti architetti da temi dei casi
perché deve andare a fare o questo ted a
ottobre e mi hanno riempito di mail
segno è che in italia qualche cosa si
muove
allora ho scelto di farvi vedere invece
solamente le cose che ho delle persone
che ho conosciuto degli eventi che ho
conosciuto nel nell'ultima nelle ultime
state questo per esempio
parto da un poeta perché io credo che i
poeti abbiano una sensibilità superiore
individuare certi certi problemi ad
individuare le tendenze questo e franco
arminio è un poeta lucano e fa un
bellissimo festival di paesologia
parlando appunto in un comune lucano in
in quota
parlando appunto di paesi che vanno
spopolandosi di montagna che va franando
di montagna che va salvaguardata del
resto il vate assoluto e per quanto
riguarda i poeti che si interessano
di ambiente e wendell berry che
estremamente popolare un po meno
conosciuto in italia estremamente
popolare negli stati uniti il poeta
contadino e alla base ed anche di molti
movimenti alla base anche a un grande
ascendente anche sui consumatori
americani wendell berry venne qua in
italia 45 anni fa mi pare perché gli è
stato dato il premio artusi a
forlimpopoli e venuto e parlando facendo
le chiacchiere di segrate che io poi ho
imparato tutto qui da voi in italia
perché da giovane sono venuto ho visto
come veniva mantenuto erano credo gli
anni 50 il territorio ho visto lo disse
in italiano harare a ritocchino le
colline toscane cioè per il loro verso
secondo la pendenza non mi sto spiegare
e ho capito che se illuminati
mi è venuto un illuminazione ho capito
tutto capito che negli stati uniti
stavano sbagliando e quindi ha
cominciato questa sua opera sia poetica
che ambientalista e lui lavorato molto
per esempio sulla responsabilità del
consumatore nei confronti del cibo degli
altri ragazzi che ho incontrato sono
questi di green farm nantes che è sono
ragazzi che hanno studiato qua in parte
qui a bologna loro hanno un progetto che
ha vinto un concorso europeo è stato
selezionato dall'unione europea per
ripopolare i8000 borghi abbandonati
italiani ripopolando lì con ragazzi che
magari stanno cercando con passione e
anche i rifugiati rifugiati quindi
comunità miste che potrebbero mi è
sembrato è un'operazione a me mi è molto
piaciuto perché anche una sua ecco una
sua poesia perché poi si tratta di
ricolonizzare il tutto sommato delle
aree per esempio loro hanno anno stanno
studiando un borgo che si chiama
libertina che ha perso nelle montagne
dei sicani monti sicari credo un altro
gruppo che ho conosciuto e questo va sap
che al di là del nome molto simpatico è
un hub agricolo che riunisce i giovani
agricoltori principalmente un gruppo
pugliese che riunisce diversi giovani
agricoltori e si stanno dando un gran da
fare per operazioni anche di marketing
territoriale di valorizzazione del cibo
sono questi ragazzi qui un gruppo di
bologna che ho conosciuto qui
all'incubatore golinelli qua a bologna
poche settimane fa e sono questi di
agronet ragazzi anche questi
giovanissimi sono degli agronomi ma ci
sono anche dei fisici lavorano su dei
modelli matematici costruiscono degli
algoritmi tecnologici che permettono di
prevedere anche i prezzi dei prodotti
ecco questa è la agricoltura moderna
un'agricoltura che che ci interessa vado
molto veloce questi sono i due vincitori
del premio city of food a cui a bologna
perché a bologna non è solamente
promozione gastronomica ristoranti e
quant'altro si sta lavora per esempio
per esempio anche con la città di new
york si lavora sugli orti urbani si
lavora sui sui tetti verdi e si lavora
su un'agricoltura per un'agricoltura in
un certo senso sostenibile perché siamo
noi
adesso vi faccio salvo qualche cosa e in
questo caso con pochissima spesa
pochissima spesa si può rinverdire una
parete questo è un condominio che verso
verso via di corticella qua con a
bologna spesa a 0 si possono anche
ricoprire di verde dei dei dei capannoni
per esempio con una spesa veramente
molto molto limitata
quello che voglio dirvi in al termine è
che siamo noi consumatori che hanno un
certo punto possiamo sostenere
questo tipo di agricoltura semplicemente
andando a premiare i prodotti di qualità
dobbiamo scegliere la qualità piuttosto
che la quantità viene a scegliere il
bene compiuto di bene comune piuttosto
che il bene individuale come abbiamo
visto nel caso della speculazione
edilizia
ti ringrazio per l'attenzione